Two incredible things happened to me today
while I was early voting in Charleston County.
By the way, if you want early vote,
you can go to see Coast Church.
It's mega evangelical church,
which we can unpack that later.
But the first thing is,
the man standing in front of me was an old veteran,
and the Republican candidate for treasurer came along the line
and started saying, hey,
does anybody have any questions?
This man grilled this candidate
about the fact that he joked a couple people up
about lowering taxes to zero.
Not only did he grill him,
he fucking torched this candidate.
And I have never seen male audacity used as a power for good,
and I fucking loved it. Secondly,
on my way out from voting,
I saw a guy walking in, the wrong way,
I might add, uh,
with a let's go, Brandon T-shirt.
So I kindly let him know. I go, dude,
they're not gonna let you in there with that shirt.
He's like, why not?
I said, cause it's political.
He goes, I don't know what's political about it.
And I said, I guess we'll have to see what they think about that,
because, sir,
come on. I'm not even sure you're aware
that Joe Biden's not on the ballot this year.